SHOW.
ALL RIGHT. HE'S A PRO FOOTBALL
HALL OF FAMER AND I FIGURED
LET'S GET THEM ON NOT ONLY
BECAUSE HE HAS A UNIQUE
PERSPECTIVE
ON TOM BRADY.
BECAUSE HE
HE
LOST
GOD GOOD LORD. TELL ME IT'S A
GUY NAMED GIOVANNI. SEE LOVE
TENDING GOATS AS A SOPHOMORE.
SHE'S A BAD MAN. 844 2004.
BUT HE ALSO KNOWS ABOUT SECOND
ACTS AND HE'S JUST A GREAT
HUMAN ON THE PLANET.
AND ALSO
CALLED ON WESTWOOD ONE, THE
RAMS WIN
OVER THE 49ERS ON SUNDAY
AND IS GOING TO CALL
SUPER BOWL, FIFTY SIX. AND SO
FIVE STADIUM IN A COUPLE
SUNDAYS FOR WESTWOOD ONE. HE'S
KIRK? ARNER. ARE YOU DOING
I'M DOING GOOD. MY FRIEND. HOW
ARE YOU? I'M DOING GREAT. WHAT
DO YOU
THINK? BRADY'S NOW, RETIRED?
WHAT?
WHAT DO YOU SAY ABOUT THAT?
AND I THINK I THINK LIKE, ALL
OF US IS FANS. YOU KNOW,
YOUR KIND OF BUMMED,
SAID REINVENT HIMSELF. AND
WHAT IS HE GOING TO DO NEXT?
AND YOU KNOW EVERYBODY, I
THINK WAITING FOR HIM
TO FALL OFF,
YOU KNOW, THE FLAT PART OF THE
EARTH AND, AND DISAPPEAR
AND NOT BE ABLE TO PLAY, LIKE
HE DID AND HE FINISHES WITH,
YOU KNOW, NUMBER ONE AND SO
YEAR AND YOU'RE JUST LIKE, HIS
IT'S JUST UNBELIEVABLE, AND
IT'S FUN. AND IT WAS A PART OF
OUR NFL THAT YOU SAID. OKAY.
THIS IS THE ONE CONSTANT THAT
WE KNOW EVERY YEAR IS
TOM BRADY'S, GOING TO HAVE A
SUPER BOWL. NOW E FOR THE
FAN. WE'RE ALL KIND OF BUMMED
AS A FAN AS WE TALKED ABOUT ON
OUR YOU KNOW, SHOW THE OTHER
DAY IS THAT
WE'RE ALL VERY THANKFUL,
YOU KNOW, NOT VERY, VERY
OFTEN. DO YOU GET A CHANCE TO
YOU KNOW WITNESS THE
ENTIRETY OF A CAREER
OF?
YOU KNOW, WHAT? I THINK MOST
OF US BELIEVE IS THE GREATEST
FOOTBALL PLAYER TO EVER PLAY
AND, YOU KNOW, AS YOU SAID I
GOT TO SEE IT UP CLOSE AND
PERSONAL AT THE BEGINNING
AND BEEN ABLE TO WATCH IT EVER
SINCE
AND
BEEN IN.
AMAZEMENT SO OFTEN OF
YOU KNOW WHAT HE'S DONE AND
YOU MADE THE POINT ON ON OUR
SHOW. ALSO THAT
THE THING ABOUT TOM BRADY IS
THAT
HE MADE IT SEEM SO EASY.
YOU KNOW, WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
TEN SUPER BOWLS AND WE TALKED
WHEN IN 70 TALK ABOUT, YOU
KNOW,
14 CHAMPIONSHIP GAMES AND ALL
OF THIS STUFF
THAT, YOU KNOW, WE JUST KIND
OF FLIPPANTLY THROW AROUND
BECAUSE IT'S TOM BRADY.
YOU KNOW, NOW, THEN YOU CAN,
I FEEL FOR SO FORTUNATE TO
HAVE PLAYED IN THREE SUPER
BOWLS
DREW.
MURRAY'S GOT TO PLAY IN ONE
AARON. RODGERS IS PLAYED IN
ONE.
PERSPECTIVE RT TO PUT IT IN
OF HOW EASY HE MADE IT
AND WHAT HE ACCOMPLISHED
ON THE
HOLE AND YOU KNOW, I THINK IN
AN ERA ALSO YOU TALKING ABOUT
IN AN ERA WHERE WE HAD
PEYTON MANNING, YOU HAD BEN
ROETHLISBERGER WHO JUST
RETIRED, YOU HAD, YOU KNOW,
BREATHES IN ROGERS. AS I
TALKED ABOUT. I MEAN, YOU TALK
ABOUT SOME OF THE GREATEST
QUARTERBACKS WE'VE EVER SEEN
IN THIS GAME AND IT WAS DURING
THAT ERA
WHERE TOM
HE DID ALL OF THIS.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, THAT
TO ME
AS A PLAYER, WHEN YOU DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW DIFFICULT IT IS
TO GET THERE ONE TIME OR TO
COMPETE AT THAT LEVEL
CONSISTENTLY YEAR IN AND YEAR
OUT
IS PROBABLY WHAT I WAS MOST
IN AWE OF
WITH TOM BRADY BECAUSE WE ALL
SIT BACK AND KIND OF WISH I
WOULD HAVE HAD ONE MORE
OPPORTUNITY
MADE IT LOOK ROUTINE EVERY
YEAR THAT THIS IS WHERE I'M
GOING TO BE. I'M GOING TO
LEAST BE IN THE AFC
CHAMPIONSHIP GAME AND I'M
PROBABLY GOING TO BE IN THE
SUPER BOWL AND THAT JUST
DOESN'T HAPPEN IN
ANY SPORT.
AND YOU KNOW, AND AGAIN IT'S
UNDERSTAND THAT IT TAKES A
TEAM
CHAMPIONSHIPS, BUT THAT GUY IN
THAT LEADER THAT YOU
HAVE THAT YOU BELIEVE IN THAT,
YOU BELIEVE EVERY TIME YOU
STEP ON THE FIELD, YOU'RE
GOING TO WIN.
IS IT DIFFERENCE MAKER? AND
THAT'S WHY, YOU KNOW, SUPER
BOWLS AND AND
WINDS GET CONNECTED TO
QUARTERBACKS BECAUSE THOSE
GUYS ARE THE DIFFERENCE
MAKERS
AND YOU JUST DID IT BETTER
THAN EVERYONE ELSE. AND SO I'M
JUST I'M THANKFUL THAT I GOT
TO WITNESS IT,
YOU KNOW, IF YOU GOT TO GET
BEAT BY SOMEBODY IN THE SUPER
BOWL,
YOU KNOW, IT'S OKAY TO SAY
TO WATCH HIM AND I FEEL LIKE
HE'S ALWAYS DONE IT
THE RIGHT WAY TO,
HE'S ALWAYS DONE IT WITH CLASS
AND CARRIED HIMSELF
THAT WAY AND SO JUST
SIT
HONOR TO HAVE COMPETED AGAINST
HIM TO WATCHED HIS
WHO HAVE WATCHED HIS CAREER
AND AND TO KNOW HIM AS A
FRIEND, YOU KNOW WHAT? AND,
AND THERE'S SO MANY WAYS TO
FOLLOW UP HERE. SO I'M GOING
TO I'M GOING TO GO, I GUESS
I GOT LIKE TWO OR THREE
FOLLOW-UPS. I'M GOING TO TAKE
THE FIRST ONE HERE ABOUT BACK
IN THE DAY.
BOWL IS NOT ANY NORMAL GAME
WHERE
YOU'RE JUST WARMING OR WHEN HE
WAS JUST A KID LOOKING FOR HIS
FIRST AND YOU'RE THAT GUY,
MAGIC CARPET RIDE THAT, BY THE
WAY, IS IN THEATERS NEAR YOU
AND AMERICAN UNDERDOG,
TERRIFIC MOVIE. SO, DID YOU
HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH HIM?
HIM A LITTLE BIT BECAUSE WE
PLAYED EARLIER THAT YEAR.
PLAYED ONCE THAT YEAR AND SO
WE SPOKE A LITTLE BIT. YOU
KNOW, HE KIND OF CAME ON THE
SCENE
SIMILAR TO THE WAY I DID.
AND JUST, YOU KNOW, KIND OF
ENCOURAGED
HIM AND SAID, HEY,
HEY, YOU KNOW YOU'RE DOING A
GREAT JOB, KEEP IT UP.
POSSIBILITIES ARE. I MEAN YOU
LOOK AT ME,
BUT, YOU KNOW,
I HAD A LONG CONVERSATION, BUT
JUST KIND OF THAT INTRODUCTORY
CONVERSATION, YOU KNOW, WITH A
YOUNG KID,
AND THEN WE DIDN'T SPEAK
BEFORE THE SUPER BOWL
BUT TALKED AFTERWARDS
AND
YOU KNOW, JUST ONE OF THOSE
THINGS THAT AGAIN AT THE TIME,
YOU KNOW,
YOU'RE DISAPPOINTED FOR
YOURSELF,
YOU KNOW FOR WHATEVER YOU CAN
BE HAPPY FOR A YOUNG KID THAT
GETS THE OPPORTUNITY AND
DOES GREAT AND WIN THE SUPER
BOWL. YOU'RE HAPPY
FOR THEM.
BUT YOU KNOW, LET'S BE HONEST.
I MEAN, I DIDN'T SEE ANY OF
THIS COMING IN THAT GAME,
YOU KNOW, THROUGH FOR LIKE
150 YARDS AND, YOU KNOW, HAD A
GREAT DRIVE AT THE END TO KIND
OF PUT THEM OVER THE TOP,
BUT YOU KNOW, IT WASN'T THIS
TOM. BRADY AND SO I GOT A
CHANCE TO KIND OF SEE
THAT AND SEE HIM
WIN
AS BEING A
COMPLEMENTARY PIECE AND AND
TO BECOMING THE TOM BRADY,
THAT WE KNOW THAT THAT LED
TEAMS AND CARRY TEAMS
TO THAT POINT. AND SO,
YEAH, WE
HAD SOME INITIAL
SHAL, YOU KNOW, SIMPLE
CONVERSATIONS
BUT NEVER WITH ANY INKLING
OF WHAT WAS AHEAD
FOR HIM. WELL, I MEAN AND
AND
WE
MAY SEE, YOU KNOW, SOMEBODY
HAVE THEIR CAREER START
ALTHOUGH WE'RE STILL WAITING
TO SOMEBODY TO GO BACK TO BACK
AS HE DID THREE IN HIS FIRST
FOUR YEARS, WINNING IT ALL AND
JOE BOROUGH HAS AN OPPORTUNITY
COMING UP SHORTLY TO GET ON
THAT ROAD,
BUT I DON'T KNOW IF WE'LL EVER
SEE ANYBODY AGAIN. DO
WHAT HE DID.
THE AGE OF 37 AND
PLAYED A 44, AND LOOK, AS
GREAT AS DOING IT.
I WONDER WHAT YOU THINK OF
THAT KNOWING WHAT YOU HAD TO
GO THROUGH TOWARDS THE END OF
YOUR CAREER.
KURT. WELL, I MEAN,
I THINK THE ONE THING THAT I
YOU KNOW, WE'VE GOT
A KIND OF A DIFFERENT BREED OF
QUARTERBACKS,
YOU KNOW, KIND OF TAKEN OVER
THE NFL NOW, YOU KNOW, THE
ATHLETIC QUARTERBACK,
THE GUY THAT CAN DO YOU KNOW,
MUCH MORE THAN JUST THROW THE
AND, ALL
YOU KNOW, I'VE ALWAYS SAID
ABOUT GUYS, YOU KNOW, LIKE
BREEZE AND
AND BRADY AND
THOSE KIND OF GUYS LIKE
MYSELF,
WHEN YOU PLAY A CERTAIN WAY
YOUR ENTIRE CAREER.
I THINK IT'S EASIER TO
AND YOU STILL HAVE THE SKILL
SET TO DO THAT. SO IN OTHER
WORDS, ALL OF US OBVIOUSLY
BEING POCKET PASTORS AND NOT
BASED ON OUR ATHLETICISM, SO
IT DIDN'T MATTER. IF WE COULD
THROW THE BALL, A FEW YARDS
LESS OR WE COULDN'T RUN THE
40 QUITE AS FAST
BECAUSE WE PLAYED IT A
DIFFERENT WAY. AND SO I ALWAYS
FELT LIKE GUYS LIKE THAT, HAD
THE
OPPORTUNITY
TO PLAY THE SAME WAY
AND HAVE THE SAME SUCCESS
LONGER
IN
THEIR CAREER.
YOU KNOW, SO I THINK THAT'S
THE FIRST THING. AND THAT'S
WHO TOM WAS AND HE
CONTINUED TO GET BETTER AND
BETTER AT WHAT HE DID,
BUT HE NEVER HAD TO CHANGE THE
WAY THAT HE PLAYED. I MEAN YOU
MIX. HE RULES IN TO THE
OBVIOUSLY THAT PROBABLY HELPED
A LITTLE BIT BUT YOU KNOW, BUT
LET'S BE HONEST. I MEAN, IT
DOESN'T MATTER WITH ALL THOSE
THINGS,
YOU KNOW, IT CAME DOWN TO
TOM BEING METICULOUS WITH
HOW HE PREPARED AND
HOW HE WORKED EVERY YEAR AND
HOW HE GOT HIS BODY READY. I
MEAN, YOU KNOW, THE AMAZING
THING IS, WE ACTUALLY THE
YEAR, WE WENT TO THE
SUPER BOWL WITH THE
THE CARDINALS WAS THE YEAR
THAT HE SUFFERED HIS KNEE
INJURY. SO WE PLAYED NEW
ENGLAND THAT YEAR AND IT WAS
MATT CASSELL AND
YOU KNOW AND OUTSIDE OF THAT
ONE SEASON AND THAT CRAZY
THE GUY REALLY HASN'T, YOU
KNOW, HAD MANY ISSUES
PHYSICALLY
WHATSOEVER, WHICH IS SO
AMAZING TO ME BECAUSE I
CAREER. I DIDN'T SUFFER A LOT
OF INJURIES, BUT THE INJURIES
CAME WITH LIKE BROKEN FINGERS
AND BROKEN PINKIES AND
EVERYTHING ON MY RIGHT HAND
WHERE I HAD TO MISS TIME AND
MISS GAMES.
THE GUY JUST DIDN'T
GAMES AND, YOU KNOW WHETHER HE
WAS
FORTUNATE FEEL TO KEEP HIMSELF
READY.
I MEAN, JUST INCREDIBLE TO
WATCH. I MEAN, YOU KNOW, THERE
WAS NO WAY, YOU KNOW, WHEN I
WAS GETTING TO THE
LEAGUE, QUARTERBACKS WERE
RETIRING AT 35, THAT WAS A
LONG CAREER.
SO, YOU KNOW, 44 I JUST
WITH ALL THESE QUARTERBACKS IN
THE WAY THEY PLAY NOW. I'M NOT
SURE
MAKE IT TO OING TO BE ABLE TO
UNLESS THEY CAN PLAY
INSIDE THE POCKET AND YOU
KNOW, AND AGAIN WE'VE GOT GUYS
JAIL, BRO. YOU MENTIONED IT,
YOU KNOW.
WE'VE GOT A NUMBER OF OTHER
GUYS THAT CAN DO THAT TO A
DEGREE,
BUT CAN THEY SUSTAIN THAT AT
THE LEVEL THAT YOU NEED TO
TO HAVE THAT TOM BRADY
TYPE
SUCCESS WILL BE FASCINATING
AND THOSE GUYS THAT ARE
ATHLETIC.
YOU KNOW, THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO EVOLVE AND PLAY THE
GAME DIFFERENTLY IF THEY WANT
TO COME ANYWHERE CLOSE TO
MY OPINION, W, TO THAT AG, IN
KURT WARNER, HERE ON THE
RICH EYES AND SHOW.
SO I HAD THE
AUTHOR, SETH WICKERSHAM'S ON
ONE KURT AND HE'S BEEN
FOLLOWING THE
PATRIOTS FOR
EVER IN A DAZE, GOT A BOOK OUT
ABOUT THEIR DYNASTY.
AND I ASKED HIM ABOUT
BRADY'S DECISION TO RETIRE AND
NOW
AND HOW I'M
KIND I WAS KIND OF SURPRISED
BY IT FOR MANY REASONS,
BECAUSE HE'S BEEN SO TERRIFIC,
BUT THE FACT IS THAT, YOU
KNOW,
HE'S NOT GIVING IT ONE MORE.
TRY TO MAKE SURE HE CAN END IT
ON A WIN, RIGHT? WITH A
SUPER BOWL WIN.
AND HERE WAS HIS RESPONSE, AND
I'M CURIOUS TO HEAR
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THE OTHER
SIDE. CHECK IT OUT.
MOMENT. I WAS AT HIS I WAS IN
HIS LIVING ROOM
AND WE WERE
SEVEN YEARS AGO. MAYBE
IT WAS BEFORE
THE SORT OF
REST OF THE DYNASTY THAT
WHICH NOT ONLY THE PATRIOTS,
BUT REALLY THE TOM BRADY
DYNASTY
KIND OF
WAS
RECLAMATION. AND AND
HE WAS TELLING ME ABOUT THEY
JUST LOST TO THE RAVENS IN THE
PLAYOFFS AND HE TOLD ME THAT
KURT WARNER HAD SENT HIM A
TEXT
AFTER THE GAME SAYING, LIKE
BEING THE BEST DOESN'T MEAN
YOU ALWAYS WIN. IT JUST MEANS
YOU WIN MORE THAN ANYBODY
ELSE.
AND THAT TEXT REALLY MEANT
A LOT TO HIM BECAUSE IT
IT SPOKE TO HIS
ESSENCE IN A WAY THAT VERY FEW
YES, IT'S ALWAYS ABOUT
WINNING, BUT IT WAS OFTEN IN
FAILURE THAT HE FOUND
SUCCESSES
AND
YOU KNOW, THE PEOPLE
THERE'S PEOPLE WHO ARGUED HE'D
NEVER LEAVE NEW ENGLAND AFTER
THROWING A PICK SIX ON HIS
FINAL, THROW
AGAINST THE TITANS, AND
THERE'S PEOPLE WHO'D ARGUE,
HE'D NEVER GO OUT
LOSING TO THE LOS ANGELES.
RAMS IN THE PLAYOFFS, BUT,
YOU KNOW, THAT WAS
IT.
IT WAS MISREAD HIM JUST A
LITTLE BIT.
WELL, I THINK THAT
WHAT HE
HE PRIDED HIMSELF ON AS MUCH
AS ANYTHING.
IS THIS KIND OF GENIUS. HE
HAD OF
REFUSING TO CONCEDE ANYONE
ELSE'S IDEA
OF THE INEVITABLE OR OF
REALITY. IN THAT REGARD.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
TO HEAR ABOUT THAT?
WELL, I MEAN,
YOU KNOW, I THINK IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE ALL
HAVE TO COME TO GRIPS WITH
IS, YOU KNOW, SO MANY OF THE
GUYS THAT PLAY
AT THIS LEVEL
ARE USED TO WINNING, AND
THEY'RE USED TO BEING THE BEST
AT WHAT THEY DO. AND
MOST
TIMES THEY FEEL
LIKE THOSE TWO THINGS ARE
SYNONYMOUS
AND, YOU KNOW, AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER, IT'S ALSO THE
ULTIMATE
TEAM GAME
AND SO
I TELL PEOPLE ALL THE TIME
SOMETIMES THE GREATEST THING
ABOUT BEING A FOOTBALL PLAYERS
THAT IT'S A TEAM GAME AND YOU
GET TO CELEBRATE THOSE MOMENTS
WITH
52 OTHER GUYS, AND THEN
SOMETIMES THE WORST THING
TEAM GAME BECAUSE IT T IT'S A
TAKES EVERYBODY. AND, YOU
KNOW, SOMETIMES OTHER
FACETS CAN LET YOU DOWN. AND
TO A REALIZATION  HAVE TO COME
OF WHAT IT MEANS TO
BE
BEST
AND BEING OUR BEST, DOESN'T
ALWAYS MEAN THAT WE WIN
ON THE SCOREBOARD AND THAT WE
HAVE MORE POINTS THAN THE
OTHER TEAM AND THAT GETS
LOST. I THINK TOO OFTEN
IN SOCIETY AS A WHOLE.
AND, YOU KNOW,
IT'S ALL ABOUT HOW MANY POINTS
YOU HAVE ON THE BOARD
AND, YOU KNOW, AND,
YOU KNOW, WHEN I TEXT AND TOM
AND I HAVE A GREAT
RELATIONSHIP AND WE WOULD, YOU
THE TIME, BUT REALLY, IT  ALL
WAS JUST
JUST UNDERSTAND WHO YOU ARE.
AND WHAT YOU'VE DONE
AND DON'T
EVER.
YOU KNOW, FEEL LIKE A
SEASONED CAN'T BE A SUCCESS
WHEN YOU DON'T FINISH
WINNING A SUPER BOWL. AND,
YOU KNOW, SO I LOVE THAT,
CONVERSATIONS WITH AVE THOSE
GUYS LIKE THAT
TO THE GREATEST OF ALL TIME
AND YOU CAN STILL
IMPRESS UPON THEM THINGS THAT
YOU'VE LEARNED
THROUGHOUT YOUR TIME AND
THROUGHOUT
YOUR JOURNEY BECAUSE THAT TO
ME IS WHAT IT'S ALL ABOUT. ALL
OF US, EVOLVING
AND COMING TO A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT IT MEANS
TO TRY TO BE OUR BEST ON A
DAILY BASIS.
AND THEN BEING
BEING ABLE TO STEP AWAY AND
THAT WE WERE THAT, AND THAT WE
DID WHAT WE NEEDED TO DO
TO BECOME THE BEST VERSION OF
OURSELVES, WHICH IS WHAT I
BELIEVE. TOM BRADY'S, ALWAYS
TRIED TO DO
KURT WARNER HERE ON THE
RICH EISEN SHOW BEFORE I LET
YOU GO.
LET'S TALK ABOUT
THE FILM THAT YOU'VE SEEN FROM
AND PIONSHIP WEEKEND
AND THEN, OBVIOUSLY THE WHAT
YOU SAW WITH YOUR OWN TWO
EYES, CALLING THE
NFC CHAMPIONSHIP
GAME, STARTING WITH THE AFC
CHAMPIONSHIP. I KNOW YOU'VE
BEEN WATCHING TAPE ON THAT
ONE.
WHAT HAPPENED TO THAT CHIEFS
OFFENSE IN THAT GAME
KURT? YEAH, I MEAN OBVIOUSLY,
YOU KNOW SO MANY THINGS,
OF THE GAME AND YOU KNOW, SE
EVERYBODY SAW THE POINTS ON
THE BOARD
EARLY IN THE GAME. AND
SOMETIMES WHEN I WATCH FILM
RICH, I'LL WATCH AND SAY,
OKAY, DID SOMETHING
HAPPENED EARLIER IN A GAME
MAYBE LEADS TO
SOMETHING NOT
HAPPENING IS HAPPENING AS
WELL,
LATER IN THE GAME.
AND WHAT DO I MEAN BY THAT,
YOU KNOW, IN THAT GAME,
PATRICK MAHOMES
HAD
YOU KNOW, A COUPLE TOUCHDOWNS
IN THE FIRST HALF WHERE IT WAS
JUST UNBELIEVABLE
SCRAMBLE PLAYS BY HIM
BY AND TIME. AND THEN
HE MAKES THESE GREAT THROWS
AND THEY GET TWO TOUCHDOWNS
OUT OF IT LATER. IN THE GAME.
THEY HAD AN OPPORTUNITY A
COUPLE OPPORTUNITIES
IN THE RED ZONE
WHERE IF PATRICK, I THINK JUST
READS THE PLAY THE WAY THAT HE
NORMALLY WOULD READ IT.
I THINK HE THROWS A COUPLE
TOUCHDOWNS THERE AND WE MAY BE
TALKING ABOUT THEM IN THE
SUPER BOWL
AND ONE SPECIFICALLY
HE GOT CAUGHT UP KIND OF
BOUNCING IN THE
ALMOST LIKE I'M NOT REALLY
READING ANYTHING. I'M JUST
BUYING TIME
ENOUGH SO I CAN GO AND
SCRAMBLE AND MAKE A PLAY.
AND SO I THINK SOMETIMES WE
FALL INTO MODES WHERE THINGS
HAVE WORKED EARLIER IN THE
GAME
AND WE TRY TO FORCE
SOMETHING
LATER IN THE GAME,
YOU KNOW, THE INTERCEPTION
THAT HE THREW OFF OF THAT, YOU
KNOW, THE RPO, THE TIP TO THE
DEFENSIVE LINEMAN.
IT WAS ACTUALLY AN RPO THAT
NORMALLY YOU WOULD READ THE
OTHER SIDE. YOU'RE READING THE
RIGHT
DEFENSIVE END AND IF
HE BITES DOWN YOU THROW IT OUT
THE RIGHT HAND SIDE.
BECAUSE THEY'VE AVOIDED THAT
AREA FOR SOME REASON.
PATRICK DECIDED TO GO AND
THROW IT TO THE
READ HAND SIDE AWAY FROM HIS
AND THROW IT TO THE
COMBINATION. THE QUICK
COMBINATION THAT WAS OUT THE
LEFT INSTEAD OF THE RIGHT,
WHICH IS JUST AGAIN, I KNOW
IT'S HAPPENED TO HIM BEFORE
AND HE SEEN IT LOOK. AND IT'S
WORKED OUT.
BUT INSTEAD OF JUST KIND OF
PLAY IN THE PLAY.
YOU KNOW, HE TRIED TO MAKE
ANOTHER PLANE AND IT WORKED
OUT AGAINST THEM AND SO
THAT TO ME IS, WHAT KIND OF
HAPPENED IS THAT EVERYTHING
MAKING EVERY HT AND THEY WERE
THAT LAST PLAY, AT THE END OF
THE FIRST HALF, WHICH
I'M STILL KIND OF CONFUSED BY
THE PLAY
CALM AND YOU KNOW, I THINK IT
WAS PATRICK SAYING
MAN. EVERYTHING ELSE IS
WORKING. SO LET ME JUST THROW
IT TO TYREKE AND HE'LL MAKE IT
WORK BECAUSE BECAUSE WE'RE
INVINCIBLE RIGHT NOW AND THEN
AFTER YOU MAKES THAT THROW,
IT'S LIKE,
OH, WAIT A SECOND THAT WASN'T
THE RIGHT DECISION AND
HE GOT A LITTLE MORE TENTATIVE
AND, YOU KNOW, I THINK HE
GAME MORE THAN JUST REACTING
AND THEN THINGS JUST DIDN'T
WORK
OUT FOR THEM.
THE SECOND HALF AND THE
MOMENTUM SWITCHED,
OTHER SIDE FOR MAKING THE
PLAYS THAT WERE AVAILABLE IN
FRONT OF THEM TO MAKE
WHETHER IT WAS DEFENSIVELY OR
OFFENSIVELY
JOE BOROUGH, MAKING SOME KEY
PLAYS REALLY WITH HIS LEGS
SHOW IS THAT HE'S KIND OF R
SNEAKY GOOD
AT, YOU KNOW, BUYING TIME IN
THE POCKET AND AND AVOIDING
SACKS IN THE POCKET AND EVEN
IF HE GAINS THREE OR FOUR
YARDS, IT'S A POSITIVE INSTEAD
OF A NEGATIVE
AND THAT WAS REALLY KIND OF
THE, YOU KNOW, THE STORY OF
THE SECOND HALF IN MY OPINION.
YOU KNOW,
THE I THOUGHT
BUT I E PLAYED GOOD,
THOUGHT, YOU KNOW, PATRICK WAS
THE FIRST ONE TO KIND OF SAY.
ME THAT E OF THAT STUFF'S ON
PATRICK DIDN'T PLAY HIS GAME
THE SECOND HALF AND WHEN
YOU'RE PLAYING AGAINST GOOD
TEAMS,
AND YOU KNOW, HOW SOME OF
THOSE THINGS AND TO GO AGAINST
YOU
AND IT'S TOUGH TO WIN.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'VE SEEN
THROUGHOUT THESE PLAYOFFS. IS
THAT ALL THESE GAMES ARE
CLOSED? OKAY, WHO'S GOING TO
MAKE THAT ONE MISTAKE? WHO'S
GOING TO DO SOMETHING? THAT'S
UNCHARACTERISTIC OF
THEMSELVES. GIVE THE OTHER
TEAM, A CHANCE AND THEN THE
OTHER TEAM, ALL THESE TEAMS
HAVE THE CHANCE TO CAPITALIZE
ON IT. AND
I MEAN, I THINK THE NFC
CHAMPIONSHIP
GAME, YOU KNOW, I THINK IT WAS
JUST A TOUGH FOUGHT FOOTBALL
GAME
WHERE AGAIN, THERE WERE SOME
MISSED OPPORTUNITIES
BY THE RAMS IN THAT GAME. THAT
KEPT THE 49ERS
AROUND. I KNOW EVERYBODY'S
KILLING, JIMMY G. I THOUGHT
JIMMY G PLAYED, ONE OF HIS
BEST GAMES,
BUT WE'RE GOING TO POINT OUT,
YOU KNOW, A COUPLE THINGS
OBVIOUSLY THAT THE MISS PASS
IN THE FIRST DRIVE, WHICH I
KNOW HE'D WANT BACK AND THEN
THE ONE TO CUDDLE YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE ONE THAT
KILLED
HIM. SO WIDE OPEN
AND THEN OBVIOUSLY THE LAST
ONE WHERE I MEAN HE HAD TO
TRY TO DO SOMETHING. HE'S
JUST TRYING TO MAKE A PLAY. SO
IT'S NOT, YOU KNOW,
FORTH AND 40, RIGHT? AND THE
BALL GETS TIPPED UP AND YOU
KNOW, BUT I THOUGHT JIMMY G
PLAYED A REALLY, REALLY GOOD
GAME
MAKING THE RIGHT DECISION
MOST OF THE TIME.
BUT YOU KNOW, BUT THE RAMS TO
ME WERE THE BETTER TEAM.
MATTHEW STAFFORD IS PLAYING
GREAT FOOTBALL,
IN THE RED ZONE THAT TURNED E
INTO AN INTERCEPTION OR YOU
KNOW, WHO
KNOWS HOW THAT GAME.
UM GOES BUT JALEN RAMSAY HAS
TWO OPPORTUNITIES TO CATCH AN
INTERCEPTION
THAT POSSIBLY FINISH THAT GAME
BEFORE THAT. WE'RE ALL TALKING
ABOUT TARTS INTERCEPTION IN
THE ONE, YOU KNOW, OR
ONE OF THE TWO MISTAKES THAT
STAFFORD MADE,
BUT JALEN RAMSAY HAD A CHANCE
TO FINISH THAT GAME. I JUST
THINK THE BETTER TEAM WHERE
THE RAMS
49ERS, YOU KNOW, DID WHAT THEY
NEEDED TO DO AND KEPT IT.
CLOSE LIKE THEY HAD UP TO THIS
POINT
IN ALL THEIR GAMES,
BUT JUST WEREN'T ABLE TO
FINISH IT AND I GIVE MORE
CREDIT TO THE RAMS
RAMS OFFENSIVELY.
WHAT THEY DID THREE STRAIGHT
DRIVES IN THE FOURTH QUARTER,
TO PUT POINTS ON THE BOARD.
YOU TIP YOUR HAT TO THEM
INCREDIBLE OBJ WAS GREAT. AND
THEN THE DEFENSE DID
WHAT YOU BROUGHT. ALL THOSE
GOT TO LEAD AT THE END FINISH
IT FOR US AND THEY WENT
OUT AND THEY FINISHED IT FOR
HIM. AND SO
A GOOD FOOTBALL GAME ON THAT
SIDE,
BUT AGAIN, I BELIEVE THE
BETTER TEAM WON
AND YOU KNOW, THE RAMS MADE
ENOUGH PLAYS TO GET
A TIGHT VICTORY WELL, BUT, YOU
KNOW, APPRECIATE THE TIME
HERE. KURT
ROLLING WITH THE PUNCHES.
PUNCHES WITH THE SHOW TODAY
AND WE DIDN'T GET YOU ON.
HOPE TO GET
JOHN MAYBE SOMETIME NEXT WEEK
IN THE
LEAD-UP TO KNOW WHAT YOU THINK
ABOUT THE MATCHUP
AND I APPRECIATE THE TWO
CENTS. I THOUGHT IT WAS PRETTY
COOL TO HEAR THAT STORY ABOUT
YOUR TEXT TO BRADY, YOU KNOW,
SOMETIMES YOU SEND A TEXT TO
SOMEBODY, YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT,
YOU KNOW WHAT IT MEANS OR HOW
IT LANDS OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT. AND HERE,
HERE WE ARE YEARS LATER, ON
THE DAY OF HIS RETIREMENT AND
SOMEBODY WHO KNOWS, BRADY
PRETTY WELL SAYING THAT MEANT
A LOT TO HIM. SO THAT'S PRETTY
COOL. YOU KNOW, I MEAN, THAT
STUFF IS COOL BECAUSE AGAIN,
YOU KNOW, DIFFERENT THINGS
ALONG THE WAY AND YOU NEVER
KNOW. YOU NEVER KNOW HOW IT'S
GOING TO PLAY OUT. EXACTLY.
AND SINCE ESPECIALLY, SINCE
ON GAME DAY MORNING YOUR KNOWN
AS SOMEBODY WHO DOES NOT GET
HIS TAX RETURN BY
QUARTERBACKS.
SO
I FELT THAT I SHOULD ONE TIME
ONE TIME AND I GET THAT.
REMEMBER ME. AMERICAN UNDERDOG
AND THEATERS NEAR YOU HOUSE
AT? DID I MAKE UP FOR IT RIGHT
NOW? OKAY. I'LL GET TO SEE
EVERYBODY GO SEE KURT'S MOVIE.
IT'S A BEAUTIFUL MOVIE KURT
AND BRENDA IS MOVING MY BAD.
GOOD TO SEE
CHAT WITH YOU CURT WILL DO
IT AGAIN. EVERYBODY. THANKS,
MAN.
IT'S OUR BEST. THAT'S THE ONE
OF THE BEST OF ALL TIME, RIGHT
THERE. AND HE
FANTASTIC FRIEND. KURT WARNER